What if all the earth's land became
ocean and all the oceans became land,
and what if our mountains turned into
deep trenches while trenches grew to the
highest peaks on the planet? Imagine
what this new world would look like.
Where on the sprawling land mass would
humanity live and why would this planet
have such a hard time sustaining life?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if
Earth's typography was inverted.
Of course, with the volume of
water in the earth's oceans,
inverting our topography would mostly
look like we flooded the planet.
Where's the fun in that?
Let's eliminate some of the world's
water so that the seven continents become
oceans and the seabed becomes
one big interconnected landmass.
It's fun to think about,
but what if I told you that a world like
this would have one major design flaw?
As far as we know,
the ocean floor is pretty boring.
Topographically speaking by and large,
it's mostly a vast plain at an average
depth of 3,700 meters below sea level.
That means,
except for the Mariana mountain range.
Our upside down world would be a huge
plateau and that would be well above the
sea level.
We're used to.
The thing is the human body doesn't
handle high altitudes. Well,
most of us live about 840 meters
above sea level are inverted.
Continent would be more than
four times higher than that.
There would be less air
pressure and less air to,
we'd have to adapt to living in a low
oxygen environment if we want it to
survive, but that's just the
beginning of our problems.
An inverted earth would be
barely covered with water.
The Himalayan trench would turn out deep,
but the rest of the seabed would,
we'd be left with four shallow oceans
and one vast never ending continent.
On the bright side, you'd be able
to walk to any part of the world,
but with little oceans left,
you probably wouldn't want to go
too far inland anyway. Right now,
71% of earth's surface
is covered with water.
The surface of an inverted earth
would only be 29% submerged.
Oceans control our climate,
distributing the heat from the
sun evenly throughout the planet.
Less water surface would
mean less evaporation and
precipitation. As a result,
most of the land would
become a scorching desert,
too hot and waterless
for humans to survive.
You'd want to live close to the oceans,
away from the unbearable
temperatures of the hot land,
but you might not stay there too
long either. With so little water,
oceans wouldn't absorb
enough carbon dioxide.
Greenhouse gases would build
up and stay in the atmosphere.
Slowly cooking the planet. Life on
earth might resemble life. On Venus,
there'd be no fresh water left to drink.
All the plants would die and all the
animals would follow shortly after humans
could build a shelter to hide from the
unbearable heat. But food would be scarce.
It would be hard to figure out how
to preserve the exist in life in such
conditions, but could life have
emerged on an inverted earth?
Theoretically, yes, and it would have
transitioned from c to lamb much earlier.
There simply wouldn't be enough real
estate at the bottom of the ocean.
If that evolutionary cycle lab
all the way to homo sapiens,
human anatomy would be very different.
Maybe we would have evolved to be cold
blooded to be able to take on the high
temperatures of our inverted planet,
but that's a story for another.
What if.